[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about where we won which
you're done
it has to be done today hey guys I'm
back here here they're really happy
about I'm really I really like working
with you guys
I'm with you why is it better working
with us then like with Kevin them do
that no no why huh why are we better
than every way than all day yeah because
there's no scandals scandal what
scandals a talking about scandals no no
that wasn't any what the s as far as I
know it was just the one big thing with
Russell but you know like scandals with
the S it's not just one can you talk
about it what's going on because I don't
know yeah you know it's unfortunate that
some some allegations were made against
Russell during the the me to movement oh
you know just kind of scared some
potential investors in the company and
kind of frightened some current
investors office to the best amount on
not be honest with you know I was
already fired
well all this should happen I got left I
got fired early on before everything hit
the fan and I fire I was I was in that
became like a day worker so fired or
like laid off layoffs because fires like
you [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] up at all like
there was like a little little Monday
they were like hey we got to cut this
show so we can say both of y'all then on
Friday I was like hey I know we said but
you fired that was just like what so I
was just like what wins my insurance ran
out so I can go hey you're firing like
are they like yeah you're late I'll feel
like I'm fired
we can't afford to pay you anymore so
sadly we're like we're sad to see you go
but Guillen's like get the [ __ ] out okay
we're going right now
definitely light up this house it was
back particular yeah because like they
let me go with them like literally a
week later two people were hired Oh
different positions and one of them was
like somebody's brother not just like
what the [ __ ] I was I had a kid Oh cuz
I've made more money as a day worker
nice flex yeah there's more freedom yeah
the only thing is like I lost was my
shirts by my head in church so I was
like I wasn't trippin off of that at all
so I was making way more money helping
shirts yep where's your wife dude she
works for a non-profit city of hope they
do cancel research and something medical
yeah yeah yeah for four years
yeah at the hospital yes you're trying
to get hired on my car you can we do a
physical robe no because this was right
after this is like in 2009-10 so it's
like the recession bad times about time
another way more money
hourly yeah and I just didn't the
benefit yeah it sucks of work at a
hospital and not al health care
seems like I just need penicillin can I
see you at work I had the penicillin can
I take this like no you don't have
insurance they're like this is the brain
surgery room please stop coming in here
at Steve Ralston it's all our get it
right sorry sir
no but um that's why I ended up leaving
that hospital and I went to go work for
an agency which it was still per diem
but then I ended up getting a pay raise
and I've got to jump around hospitals
and I feel with the [ __ ] [ __ ] so
you had to did you ever just say [ __ ] it
in his mouth like it turns out of pocket
or at that time even though it was like
I was still making like underwear I
could still have Medicare for my son
yeah okay okay that's good that did you
have a tool is it just for you son you
know what I don't understand is you get
punished if you don't pay insurance I
think they just lifted that right so but
for the last week that was a llama care
yeah first part if I didn't get
insurance it's like you don't even have
money for insurance and you have to [ __ ]
it and if you're too busy decide yeah
then you gotta you gotta pay as a
penalty because you didn't get insurance
what the [ __ ]
because that what they ask this is a
place for you to be able to afford it
like if you made under certain dollar
amount then you could get you to sign up
for Medicare you can get free assure
they didn't sign up at all for anything
yeah then deal you be penalized but like
if I paid like [ __ ] two G's a year
for that yeah yeah might as well just
well good paid forgery yes something way
cheaper to pay preserves
well no it wasn't Evan it was actually
more expensive will you paint them will
you make into my suit for Medicare I
think it was something like that yeah
there's some potential but then it's
like I also have cost of living in
California is nuts
so I'm like I can't afford it I'm sorry
move it to California
I know people come are you originally
from like you know I want to [ __ ]
leave I don't want to be here I'm only
here because my job if I could do I'm
with you man hi to all of it everyone
else though no maybe we coming out here
just for the party life is [ __ ] just
vacation don't LA yes nobody's come out
here to hang on the I love Ellen end up
staying here
rappers - rapper stop here you guys
already rich you have to wrap any
[ __ ] west I'm moving over [ __ ]
rappers yeah you can make records
anywhere you can make like looking go to
where does once Kanye's ranch in
Nebraska Omaha
I'm sure Montana what a [ __ ] Montana
mag go by Detroit Detroit is like six
hundred thousand dollars you could make
sound anywhere you can I mean you don't
have to get another [ __ ] traffic to
avoid get into a helicopter of war
traffic either yeah it's all these dang
rappers it's yeah [ __ ] rappers man
millions of rappers in the city
Oh worse or everybody thinking I think
around just go some [ __ ] where else
man what's not what's not super
inhabited Fresno no fresh ha get that
[ __ ] Mormon life going going great
religion yeah the code is pretty empty
yeah I would have met and what they ever
they have a clear math problem in North
Dakota
oh they ever met a lot of they that was
that's the kampung campaign
it says it's like North Dakota has a
meth problem let's talk about it that
was like damn that's pretty cut-and-dry
right on the know what is it like a
bunch of white dudes with overalls
smoking meth I don't I don't know I
would imagine something similar to that
though I think the white dude with
overalls are working it's dirty kids
what yeah
isn't that what those trucker drugs are
you know we're like when you go to
7-eleven there's all these trucker drugs
right and it's like extreme energy oh no
that's that's pathetic
Spanish Fly dance yeah those things
that's for sex yeah
Spanish ly absolutely legal viagra we're
selling you legal things at the counter
no I just thought it was like legal mess
like oh they got to stay away for the
next okay no I think it's for sex should
I try some why you need it yeah for fun
I mean I just learned math is not for
fun how was it I didn't wait what did
you say I'm trying some of the stuff
that work good I don't I'm sure I'm sure
y'all have done some of the same ass I
don't know that this is done god I don't
want to like do free / like oh no oh you
talked about it already
you pulled it out yeah I'm talking about
that 7-eleven like the ones yeah like at
a oh yeah I tried to Rhino once it was
one called the Rhino plant invalidity
Oh goddamn thing I've been curious about
the girl ones what what are they
supposed to do like make you super
wedding [ __ ] but it's a vibrator lady
cuz I'm like does is this all [ __ ]
but then I don't want to use my body to
experiment it yeah well you're not
committed to you say would not feed it
feed it to the cat in a cat with it and
then see if the cat gets all horny or
all these pills work that I could try
new pals man
Gatsby perverts already i cants always
rub the ads up against you like [ __ ]
stick their ass get the [ __ ] off you
white [ __ ] VP yes you want some of this
like no [ __ ] out of me we live in a porn
world to me cats are never horny enough
tan [ __ ] for me you have guy cats right
huh you have two guys Thank You male
cats
oh yeah a few cats they rub up on you
hey these guys do this [ __ ] too but it's
just not I mean I'm talking about I've
seen the chicks ask it split open you
know I've seen that I've seen her suck a
dick that came out of her [ __ ] so
when I see that and then I see a cat rub
it on somebody I'm like that's not bad
warning
I don't want it that bad but they do
want it bad enough to know that [ __ ]
cat pick and spiky and they're still
getting it some of the porn I've seen
makes me question why people like this
one time I saw this lady hey yum-yum
haven't you heard that okay yup
someone's yong-jo well it's just
interesting right because there's one
where there's a really big bedpost and
then she passed it's on no internal
organs I'm saying the bedpost and I seen
the the stair post thing too I was like
why try that why would you be like be no
wonder in a butthole fits what compels
you to put such an item in your [ __ ]
now did you that hard the same thing
that compels someone to [ __ ] hand yeah
but no Bao is drunk I [ __ ] the beach
I was drunk that's a very grainy they're
not drunk you guys you might you have
you tried to make an ass cheeks and yeah
like a sad castle a sad person
[ __ ] that she got horny yeah good it
does not matter doing that with sand so
that it could [ __ ] it could [ __ ] the
mound and I'm like that's pretty much
[ __ ] out of the beach shape it into an
asset of the quartic hashtag me too if
the cat's trying to come on to you and
you know you know yes you should
really [ __ ] I feel uncomfortable Wow not
like
I don't know did you go to a shady
looking this is my Peters this is where
I want you in or around so you have
three holes you have three holes we have
sex
okay I won't draw this boat it's it's
[ __ ] bullet points writing exactly
like step one we're gonna do this at
this time later on the dot we got number
one at 3:30 Tuesday we're gonna have sex
August I'm at home did you tell I have
date time location in the positions
we're gonna do doggy style for 30
minutes and then so as we both know Geo
you have three holes and I have only two
so what we're gonna do is we are going
we have to figure out how to divide
I'm failing by it's hard it's hard
writing I get tools so that we can both
fairly come at least one time and so how
we how do we get there
it's one of you is that if that is what
you do with the work out they said I
have a program for self are sex yes and
yes it doesn't always make sense
eventually over time you improve we're
talking we're talking about it and then
I think when we got older we just like a
comfort way more you know just like in
the bed is the most comfortable yeah
being home yeah being home and inside
its I'm still excited about [ __ ]
places you're not supposed to [ __ ]
that's true you know I got jacked off in
Ali I've [ __ ] on the on the 110 just
on the freeway how'd the freeway cause I
literally just pull it over and got it
all right there by the Staples Center
right past the stable sitting like
literally like literally like like right
pass right past us see okay
and like is Adams I'm on um I'm still on
the highway you pulled over like you're
tired I got sucked off on the two and
then I came on the 405 on the travel
well we had to go we don't work around
mid work around hurts so bad that's a
long time for those how is even get
close he took no no she was she was
giving me a hand job on the side streets
while we made our way right now
if I did not have to be here they're
gonna crash I don't know what to do I'm
gonna pull over and park and then I [ __ ]
you're finished and it was a guy walking
his dog and he passed us up oh [ __ ] she
open the door [ __ ] it spit it out we
[ __ ] left to work the white council
Zuzu came through Joe's like [ __ ] then
she made a face like this was sour
afterward she said she grabbed a bunch
of paper dolls I handed by car and
started [ __ ] scraping or holding on
with it
so that tells me both of you guys are
followers when that first try to get
ahead like chicks never ever swallowed a
there was something always be right
well I moved out here to LA every but
every chick was like yeah that's what I
do I was like I had never expected
Midwest I never experienced six just
taking it all it's more convenient isn't
it yeah I mean it definitely doesn't
kill the mold as much as like her
getting up negative just your mouth no
they don't waste things here in LA
that's not true cuz TIFF just said that
she stole about $2,000 worth of food
every [ __ ] year yeah but here they
read some article about how their
symbiotic [ __ ] and benefits to come
and then they you know here they're all
about this man then they saw want to
suck everyone off their skin looks great
that's all that's not to drink a
pineapple juice out of the can she's
like a whole [ __ ] can just laugh did
you try tasting it uh-huh
what my own said yeah no I guess not
never tried it but I had come spit it in
my mouth
if you never tried it but you had come
spitting your mouth I mean the one thing
your [ __ ] it was my Kong she [ __ ] off
she kissed weave spinning in my mouth oh
oh how did it taste
it tastes like snot flavor though what
just like this on live on snot I'm
afraid of you I'm afraid of the colonic
I'm very afraid of your answer I didn't
drink it okay I didn't drink it I was
how did you suck you all it is you took
it all and you like yeah that swallowed
it she stumped on your foot disability
impose your mouth down a major swath of
it kept doing it why not just follow it
hmm no especially when you put it like
that I couldn't working at the office
why it's weird for guys to think about
doing that for our own stuff but like I
like my girls like tasting so [ __ ]
is when you're with somebody they they
swallow like the first couple times and
then they never do it again do that one
time maybe she got bored but then you
went back to swallow me is I can't see
how good for you most improved I just
say this on stage but I was so sincere
about like chicks that don't swallow it
made no sense to me
if you don't swallow but you still drink
orange juice with pulp was like this is
the same consistency yeah the ones on
shoes one is jizz okay different
temperatures do okay so would you like
chilled jeez
no I want orange flavored jizz well put
some Tang in the back of your cheek
right will you take think that's funny
the argument is he's ready to lick that
up - to me the argument is one came from
a tree and the other one did definitely
not and that I think it's just a smaller
tree it's a flesh tree with trees I did
you guys think that you could actually
like you remember those Tropicana
commercials with the orange and a stride
did you think you could really do that I
[ __ ] up so many straws trying to do
that since what can I get those from
coolest-looking cup every yeah I was
like the best like marketing ever cuz
they stood strong inside of an orange
and you can guess it would never work
you will die cartoons got me into
coconuts - cuz these two [ __ ] always
cut coconuts open and they would fall
open perfectly and have the milk you
brought up coconuts we've just started
talking about is it made me think about
a coconut coconut jizz guy do you
remember we did this Jake a news story
so long ago but there was this guy that
kept digging into a coconut and he was
saving it by his bed oh oh yeah I
remember this yogurt that's great it's a
[Applause]
[Music]